in Milwaukee true story five baby
squirrels were found with their tails
all tangled together
this is a photo yes all tangled together
here's the good news the Wisconsin
Humane Society was able to anesthetize
them then untangle them and they're fine
now take a look everyone oh yeah yeah no
here they're just sleeping in that photo
but like they're fine they look dead
no they're all fine they are
zonked out of their minds but they came
out of that drug haze and apparently all
five are fine now unfortunately I cannot
say the same for our five crew guys
whose pony tails got tangled this
morning how's it going over there guys
not great Conan our ponytails are still
all tangled together yeah well how did
you get them tangled in the first place
what happened well we were taking our
afternoon communal nap there during
which we all sleep with our heads on the
same huge pillow yeah and that's when I
started dreaming that I was in a shampoo
commercial and started seeing my hair
around and the way they doing those
commercials and then coincidentally I
started dreaming that I was a horse
galloping through a sun-dappled field
and shaking my glorious Mane and I was
dreaming that I played bass for
Metallica and I was just thrashing my
hair all around and I couldn't sleep so
I thought as a practical joke I just tie
all the ponytails
great we'll just untangle yourself so
you can get back to work okay yeah we
definitely will we're we're trying our
hardest guys it doesn't look like you're
doing anything we're on break [ __ ]
[Applause]
you